GROUPTHINK.
SEAN HANNITY TAKES IT AWAY.
>> FIERY SPEECH.
WELCOME ABOARD.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN VERY
CLOSELY TO THIS MONOLOGUE.
THIS SCHUMER SHAM SCHIFF SHOW IS
OVER AND I’M GOING TO TELL YOU
WHY IT’S OVER.
I LISTEN CLOSELY TO EVERY DETAIL
OF THE PRESIDENTS DEFENSE,
INCLUDING THE ACTIONS OF QUID
AND PRO AND QUO JOE AND ZERO
EXPERIENCE HUNTER AND HOW JOE
SHUT DOWN THE COUNTRY OF
UKRAINE.
EVERYONE LOOKED AT WHAT HUNTER
AND JOE DID AND WERE DOING AND
SAID DON’T DO THIS.
HUNTER HAS ZERO EXPERIENCE IN
UKRAINE.
NO EXPERIENCE IN OIL.
NO EXPERIENCE IN GAS.
NO EXPERIENCE IN ENERGY.
HUNTER BIDEN GOT A WHOPPING
$84,000 A MONTH.
DID YOU KNOW PAM BONDI TOLD US
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN FAMILY OF
FOUR MAKES LESS THAN $54,000 IN
A YEAR.
EVERYONE KNEW.
EVERYONE KNOWS NOW.
EVERYONE SAW THIS AT THE TIME
FOR WHAT THIS WAS.
AND THEN YOU HAVE JOE BIDEN.
WE JUST PASSED THE TWO-YEAR
ANNIVERSARY.
JOE BIDEN ON TAPE ADMITTING TO
THE SHAKEDOWN.
EITHER WAY, AT A MINIMUM,
EVERYONE SEES WHAT THIS IS.
WE CAN IDENTIFY IT.
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED SEVERAL
POTENTIAL SERIOUS VIOLATIONS OF
THE LAW, FELONY.
LOOK AT THIS ON YOUR SCREEN.
THE FOREIGN CORRUPT PRACTICES
ACT.
15 USC 78, "IT’S ILLEGAL FOR A
U.S. PERSON TO COERCE," YOU ARE
NOT GETTING THE BILLION
UNLESS YOU FIRE.
OR INFLUENCE THROUGH BRIBERY OR
EXTORTION.
IF YOU FIRE HIM, YOU GET THE
INTO TAKING ACTION THAT MIGHT
FINANCIALLY BENEFIT THAT PERSON,
HUNTER, OR BUSINESS.
THAT’S NOT ALL.
WHOEVER CORRUPTLY GIVES OFFERS
OR PROMISES ANYTHING OF VALUE TO
A PUBLIC OFFICIAL TO INFLUENCE
AN OFFICIAL ACT IS GUILTY OF
BRIBERY.
NOT GETTING THE BILLION UNLESS
YOU FIRE THE PROSECUTOR PAYING
MY ZERO EXPERIENCE ON 83 GRAND A
MONTH.
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
DOLLARS.
OH, WE FOUND OUT THE LAW.
THE GRATUITIES ACT.
18 USC TWO OH 1B.
GIVING OFFERING, PROMISING
ANYTHING OF VALUE TO A PUBLIC
OFFICIAL IN EXCHANGE FOR ANY
OFFICIAL ACT.
IN THE HOBBS ACT.
18 USC 1951.
A THREAT TO A FOREIGN OFFICIAL
IN ORDER TO OBTAIN AN OFFICIAL
BENEFIT AFFECTING INTERSTATE,
FOREIGN COMMERCE WOULD
CONSTITUTE EXTORTION.
NEVER FORGET, IT’S THE PRESIDENT
OF PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES’ DUTY, HIS SWORN
DUTY, TO FAITHFULLY EXECUTE THE
LAWS OF THE LAND.
TONIGHT THE COUNTRY NOW NEEDS TO
MAKE A TRANSITION.
THIS B.S. WITCH HUNT IS OVER.
IT HAS TO BE OVER.
THE PRESIDENT WILL RIGHTLY BE
ACQUITTED AND VINDICATED FOR
GOOD REASON AND I’LL EXPLAIN.
GO BACK TO THE TRUMP-ZELENSKY
CALL THAT THE PRESIDENT RELEASED
FREELY.
DURING THE CALL, WHAT WAS THE
PRESIDENT WORRIED ABOUT?
HE WAS WORRIED ABOUT UKRAINIAN
CORRUPTION.
HE WAS CONCERNED, REMEMBER
ZELENSKY WAS WORKING WITH SOME
OF THE SAME BAD ACTORS IN THE
PREVIOUS UKRAINIAN
ADMINISTRATION.
AND HE WORRIED UKRAINE HAD
INTERFERED IN THE 2016 ELECTION
SEPARATE AND APART FROM RUSSIAN
INTERFERES THAT DEVIN NUNES
WARNED US ALL ABOUT.
A COURT HAVE DETERMINED
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS INTERFERED
IN OUR ELECTION.
JANUARY 2017.
JANUARY 11 TO BE EXACT.
INVESTIGATIVE REPORT FROM
POLITICO DETAILED UKRAINIAN
INTERFERENCE.
WE HAVE DESCRIBED IN DETAIL.
AFTER, BY THE WAY, THREE YEARS,
NEVER ENDING, NONSTOP, LYING,
HYSTERIA ABOUT FOREIGN ELECTION
AND THE PARENTS.
IT WOULD’VE BEEN A DERELICTION
OF DUTY, WOULD IT NOT, FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO NOT RIGHTLY
ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
DO US A FAVOR.
MY COUNTRY’S BEEN THROUGH ALL OF
THIS.
CAN WE GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT?
HE NEVER MENTIONED AID OR A QUID
OR A PRO OR A QUO LIKE JOE.
ON THE CALL IN QUESTION, NOT A
PENNY EVER MENTIONED.
THERE ARE WEAK REPUBLICANS IN
THIS COUNTRY, SO-CALLED MODERATE
DEMOCRATS IN THE U.S. SENATE,
THINKING ABOUT GETTING
VALIDATION TO THIS SCHUMER
SCHIFF SHAM SHOW WITH NEW
WITNESSES AND INVESTIGATIONS.
TO ALL OF YOU THINKING ABOUT IT,
YOU’RE NOT ONLY RIPPING THE
COUNTRY APART, YOU ARE SPEAKING
IN THE FACE OF EVERY LAW-ABIDING
AMERICAN.
THIS PRESIDENT WAS LOOKING OUT
FOR THEIR MONEY, YOUR
CONSTITUENTS.
SIMULTANEOUSLY TRAMPLING ON AND
TREADING THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES BECAUSE OF WHAT, A
SHAMEFUL POLITICAL STUNT BECAUSE
YOU CAN’T WAIT 280 DAYS KNOWING
YOU’RE LIKELY GOING TO, WELL,
LOSING THE NEXT ELECTION.
HOW STUPID AND DANGEROUS DO YOU
WANT TO BE?
THE B.S. RUNNING BOLTON IS JUST
THE LATEST MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
I’VE KNOWN JOHN BOLTON FOR I
THINK TWO DECADES, THEREABOUTS.
I HAVE A MESSAGE FOR JOHN BOLTON
TONIGHT.
USED TO BE A COLLEAGUE HERE AT
THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
I REMEMBER WHEN JOHN WAS FIRST
UP FOR THE JOB OF THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR.
I HAD HEARD THROUGH MANY SOURCES
JOHN WAS CALLING EVERYONE THAT
WOULD LISTEN IN, ASKING THEM TO
PUT IN A GOOD WORD FOR HIM WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE WANTED THIS JOB BADLY.
I SPOKE ON AN OCCASION TO
JOHN BOLTON, AND I ASKED HIM
WHAT HE WANTED THE JOB AND I
ALSO REMEMBER ASKING HIM, YOU
KNOW, DONALD TRUMP FOREIGN
POLICY POSITIONS A VERY
DIFFERENT THAN YOUR FOREIGN
POLICY POSITIONS.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO SERVE
HIS AGENDA, NOT YOURS?
AGAIN, I’VE KNOWN HIM FOR TWO
DECADES.
I’M NOT TODAY RECOGNIZING THE
GUY THAT I THOUGHT I KNEW
BECAUSE JOHN BOLTON JOHN BOLTON,
I SAY TO YOU TONIGHT, YOU HAVE
SOMETHING TO SAY, JOHN, COME
HERE.
YOU WORKED HERE.
THIS IS YOUR OLD HOME.
COME ON THE SHOW.
HAVE YOUR SAY ON THIS SHOW.
WE’VE INVITED YOU REPEATEDLY.
RADIO AND TV.
OVER THE PAST NUMBER OF WEEKS.
NOBODY I THINK TRULY KNOWS
WHAT’S IN HIS BOOK EXCEPT FOR
WHATEVER MANUSCRIPT HE MIGHT’VE
SET TO EVER SEEN IT.
I HAVE NO IDEA IF ANY OF THESE
REPORTS ARE TRUE.
BUT LET’S ASSUME FOR A SECOND
THAT THEY ARE TRUE.
HERE’S THE BOTTOM LINE.
JIM JORDAN HAS REMINDED US FOUR
FACTS NEVER CHANGE.
THIS CASE IS OVER.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY TRUMP-ZELENSKY
TRANSCRIPTS, THEY SHOW ZERO
LINKAGE BETWEEN U.S. AID IN ANY
INVESTIGATION.
ONE FACT WITNESS IN THE HOUSE
SAID WHEN HE ASKED THE PRESIDENT
WHAT DO YOU WANT, NOTHING.
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
NO QUID PRO QUO OR QUO.
TRUMP AND ZELENSKY HAVE DENIED
REPEATED THAT ANY AID WAS
CONDITIONAL.
NEVER ANY PRESSURE WHATSOEVER.
ZELENSKY EVEN GOING SO FAR AS
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT, WHAT
ARE YOU DOING?
AT THE TIME OF THE INITIAL CALL,
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS NEVER KNEW
THAT THE U.S. AID WAS
TEMPORARILY PAUSED.
DON’T FORGET, THIS IS CRITICAL.
EVEN IF DONALD TRUMP MAY BE SAID
THEY’D BETTER DO THIS OR I’M NOT
GIVING THEM ANY AID, LET’S
ASSUME HE MIGHT’VE EVEN SAID
THAT, DOESN’T MATTER, DOESN’T?
THE FOUR FACT THE NEVER CHANGES,
IN ONE CASE EARLIER WITH ZERO
STRINGS ATTACHED.
THAT MEANS I GOT THE AID.
THEY NEVER DID ANYTHING.
THEY NEVER SAID THEY WOULD DO
ANYTHING.
THEY NEVER CALLED FOR AN
INVESTIGATION.
THEY NEVER SAID THEY WOULD CALL
FOR AN INVESTIGATION.
AND THEY HAVE SENT ALL OF THAT
REPEATEDLY.
I ADD ONE FIFTH, WELL, IF YOU
WILL, FACT THAT WILL NEVER
CHANGE.
THERE WERE FIVE SEPARATE
SUBSEQUENT HIGH-LEVEL MEETINGS.
IN THE MEETINGS WITH ZELENSKY.
ALL THOSE AUDITION WITNESSES,
HEARSAY OPINION WITNESSES, HAVE
ALL SAID THE SAME THING.
AID WAS NEVER DISCUSSED.
LINKAGE WAS NEVER BROUGHT UP.
SO YOU HAVE HERE AN ANONYMOUS
SOURCE TELLING, WHAT, A LIBERAL
HACK FOR "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
THAT HATES DONALD TRUMP THAT
JOHN BOLTON AND THE MANUSCRIPT,
WELL, IS CLAIMING THE PRESIDENT
WANTED UKRAINE TO INVESTIGATE
THE BIDENS AND MAY BE ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
OKAY, LET’S ASSUME THAT’S TRUE.
THAT’S A BIG "IF," CONSIDERING
IT’S "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
LET’S SAY IT’S TRUE.
DOESN’T MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE?
WELL, I WOULD ANSWER ABSOLUTELY
NONE.
THE DOJ AND THE CHIEF OF STAFF
MICK MULVANEY TOTALLY REFUTE
BOLTON’S CLAIMS.
NOW YOU HAVE CONFLICTING
TESTIMONY.
AT BEST BOLTON’S TESTIMONY WOULD
BE HEAVILY DISPUTED BUT AGAIN,
THE FACTS DON’T CHANGE.
EVEN THEN IT DOESN’T MATTER ONE
BIT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ALLOWED TO
TALK.
HE’S ALLOWED TO EXCHANGE IDEAS
WITH HIS CLOSE ADVISORS.
THAT’S NOT A CRIME.
IT’S KIND OF LIKE, WELL, YOU
TELL YOUR FRIEND I WANT TO ROB
THIS JEWELRY STORE.
I WANT TO ROB THIS GROCERY
STORE, CONVENIENCE STORE.
OH, I’M GOING TO PUNCH THIS GUY
THE FACE.
I’M GOING TO RIP SOMEBODY’S FACE
OFF.
BUT YOU NEVER DO IT.
YOU WEREN’T SERIOUSLY PLOTTING
THE ACT.
THAT WOULD NOT BE A CRIME, WOULD
IT?
WE ALL THINK ABOUT THINGS,
THOUGHTS FLOW THROUGH OUR BRAINS
COSTLY, AT LEAST IF YOU’RE
CONSERVATIVE.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THINGS,
THAT’S NOT A CRIME.
IN ANY WAY.
IN THE WHITE HOUSE, IT’S
CERTAINLY NOT A CRIME TO TALK
ABOUT POLICY IDEAS OR TO VENT.
IF THE PRESIDENT DID WHAT THEY
SAID, IT WOULD STILL BE SO
INSIGNIFICANTLY MEANINGLESS THAT
IT WOULD NEVER ARISE TO THE
LEVEL OF QUID PRO QUO JOE AND
SYRIA EXTREME HUNTER
SO FOR YOU SENATORS, IF YOU’RE
GOING TO VALIDATE THOUGHT CRIMES
TO SMEAR A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT, 280 DAYS BEFORE THE
ELECTION WHEN THE FACTS NEVER
CHANGE.
JOHN BOLTON CAN SAY OH, NO.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THERE’S GOING
TO BE LINKAGE.
BUT THERE NEVER WAS.
WE WILL BE IN BIG TROUBLE IN THE
COUNTRY IF YOU LEGITIMIZE THIS.
JOHN BOLTON, COME ON THE SHOW.
YOUR COUNTRY WANTS TO HEAR FROM
YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM YOU.
YOU HAVE A STORAGE TELL THE
COUNTRY, JOHN, STOP PLAYING
GAMES.
THIS IS NOT A GAME WHEN IT’S THE
PRESIDENCY OF THE UNITED STATES.
IT’S NOT A GAME WHEN YOU’RE
PUSHING THE BOUNDARIES OF
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, WHICH
GEORGE WASHINGTON USED, AND
EVERY PRESIDENT PRETTY MUCH IN
BETWEEN AND SINCE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE TRIAL OF THE LEADER OF
THE FREE WORLD AND THE DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, IT IS NOT A GAME
OF LEAKS AND UNSOURCED
MANUSCRIPTS.
THAT’S POLITICS, UNFORTUNATELY.
TO BE SPECIFIC, YOU CANNOT
IMPEACH A PRESIDENT ON AND
UNSOURCED ALLEGATION.
BUT TO HAVE A REMOVAL OF THE
DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT BASED ON
A POLICY DISAGREEMENT, THAT’S
NOT WHAT THE FRAMERS INTENDED.
IF YOU LOWER THE BAR THAT WAY,
DANGER, DANGER, DANGER.
>> Sean: JAY IS RIGHT.
WHAT’S HAPPENING HERE IS
DANGEROUS.
A SMALL GROUP OF REPUBLICAN
SENATORS, WELL, THEY ARE THE CAN
OF CAVING TO THE DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES.
MAYBE THEY WANT TO BE LIKE.
MAYBE THEY ARE PUTTING THEIR OWN
ELECTION RESULTS AHEAD OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
AND WHAT’S IN THE BEST INTERESTS
OF THE COUNTRY AND THE PRINCIPLE
OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE IN THE
RIGHT OF A PRESIDENT TO GET FREE
AND FAIR AND OPEN ADVICE FROM
HIS TOP ADVISORS.
MAYBE THEY WANT THE DEMOCRATS TO
GET ALL THE WITNESSES THEY WANT.
MAYBE THEY WANT THE SPEAR TO GO
ON AND ON AND BECAUSE OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SAYING IN A
MANUSCRIPT THAT BOLTON MIGHT
HAVE SAID THAT THE PRESIDENTS
HAD LINKAGE BUT LINKAGE NEVER
HAPPENED.
I WANT TO ADDRESS MITT ROMNEY.
I LIKED MITT ROMNEY.
I THINK HE WOULD’VE BEEN A GREAT
PRESIDENT IN 2012.
HE WAS THE BETTER PERSON TO BE
PRESIDENT.
I THOUGHT I WAS FRIENDS WITH
MITT ROMNEY.
I DON’T RECOGNIZE THIS GUY
ANYMORE.
ANOTHER ONE.
HE HAS BEEN A HUGE
DISAPPOINTMENT.
I THOUGHT HE WOULD’VE BEEN A
BETTER PRESIDENT THAN OBAMA.
WE ALL WENT ALL IN, WANTED HIM
TO WIN, LIKED HIS FAMILY, WIFE,
KIDS, WONDERFUL PEOPLE.
THIS SANCTIMONIOUS TRUMP HATRED
IS GETTING OLD, ESPECIALLY AS
YOU WATCH THE PRESIDENT
ACCOMPLISHING EVERYTHING YOU
SAID, MITT ROMNEY, YOU WANTED TO
HAVE HAPPENED IN THE COUNTRY.
REALLY?
LOOK AT THE FOUR FACT, I WILL
SAY FIVE, THAT NEVER CHANGE.
UKRAINIANS SAID THEY NEVER FELT
PRESSURE.
THEY NEVER, EVER DID A SINGLE
THING.
THEY NEVER SAID THEY WOULD DO A
THING AND THEY GOT ALL THEIR
MONEY.
SO DO YOU REALLY THINK THAT YOU
SHOULD TAKE ON THE ROLE OF THE
U.S. HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES,
THE SOLE CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE TO
IMPEACH, NOW YOU WANT TO PUT ON
A WHOLE OTHER CASE AND TAKE ON
THEIR JOB?
ALL I SEE, WITH ALL DUE RESPECT,
MITT ROMNEY, IS YOUR PERSONAL
HATRED FOR DONALD TRUMP, AND
IT’S CLEARLY CLOUDING YOUR
JUDGMENT.
DO YOU REALLY THINK AMERICANS
ARE TOO STUPID TO CHOOSE THEIR
PRESIDENT?
MITT ROMNEY, SENATOR, WE HAVE AN
ELECTION IN 280 DAYS.
WHY DON’T YOU GO OUT AND
CAMPAIGN FOR QUID OR PRO OR QUO
JOE.
I HAVEN’T HEARD YOU TALK ABOUT
QUID PRO QUO OR ZERO EXPERIENCE
HUNTER AND I HAVEN’T HEARD YOU
ASK THEM TO BE CALLED AS
WITNESSES.
REALLY?
YOU ARE NOT PUTTING THE BILLION
UNLESS YOU FIRE THE PROSECUTOR
THAT’S INVESTIGATING MY ZERO
EXPERIENCE ON.
YOU DON’T WANT HIM AS A WITNESS?
DO YOU NOT THINK THAT THE
RESIDENT KNOWINGNESS IS SAYING
WOW.
THAT SEEMS REALLY BAD.
AND MITCH, I WAS SENT TO YOUR
OFFICE TOMORROW ALL THE
APPLICABLE LAWS IN THE CASE OF
QUID PRO QUO JOE AND ZERO
EXPERIENCE HUNTER.
BY THE WAY, THE MEDIA THAT IS
LOVING YOU NOW, THEY WERE THE
SAME PEOPLE THAT WERE OUT THERE
SAYING YOU ARE MISOGYNIST, YOU
ARE A RACIST, YOU CUT SOME KIDS
HERE IN GRADE SCHOOL.
THEY WERE THE ONE SAYING
EVERYTHING AND ANYTHING ABOUT
YOU TO DESTROY YOU.
DO YOU THINK THEY LIKE YOU?
DO YOU THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
LIKE YOU?
NEVER.
THIS GOES FOR YOU OTHER
REPUBLICAN SENATORS.
DO YOU REALLY BELIEVE THE VERY
SAME DEMOCRATS I’VE ACCUSED THAT
INNOCENT MAN, JUSTICE KAVANAUGH,
OF BEING A SERIAL GANG RAPIST
AND PUT THE COUNTRY THROUGH ALL
OF THAT MESS, ARE YOU GOING TO
BELIEVE THE SAME CONGENITAL
LIARS THAT PUSH THE RUSSIAN HOAX
CONSPIRACY THEORIES FOR OVER
THREE YEARS?
NEVER TOUCHED HILLARY CLINTON’S
DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
NEVER TOUCHED PREMEDITATED FRAUD
ON THE FISA ABUSE, SPYING ON A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN,
TRANSITION TEAM AND A
PRESIDENCY.
YOU WANT TO TRUST THOSE GUYS?
THE HACKS LIVE IN PLOTTING
IMPEACHMENT SINCE 2016, ALL
THROUGH 2017, 18, 19.
THIS BOLTON HYSTERIA
MANUFACTURED CRISIS, TO USE A
TERM, IS JUST THE LATEST EXAMPLE
IN WHAT IS, LET’S SEE, THEY
MEDIA MOB, STATE RUN MEDIA FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC RADICAL SOCIALIST
PARTY AND THEY ARE PHONY
SELECTIVE MORAL OUTRAGE.
IT IS THE LATEST SO-CALLED
BOMBSHELL.
EVERYTHING IS A BOMBSHELL.
DESTROYING THIS ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS IT, WE’VE GOT IT.
IT’S A BOMBSHELL.
BOMBSHELL, BOMBSHELL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> BOMBSHELL, FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR JOHN BOLTON
READY TO TURN ON THE PRESIDENT.
NEWS LEAKS FROM HIS EXPLOSIVE
NEW BOOK.
>> BOLTON DROPPED THE BOMBSHELL
IN AN UNPUBLISHED MANUSCRIPT FOR
HIS FORTHCOMING BOOK.
AN EXPLOSIVE NEW ACCOUNT FROM
FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
JOHN BOLTON.
>> JOHN BOLTON’S BOOK, WHICH IS
AS EXPLOSIVE AS EXPECTED.
>> BOMBSHELL REPORT UPENDING THE
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> BOLTON BOMBSHELL.
>> THE NEW BOOK BY JOHN BOLTON
IS CALLED "THE ROOM WHERE IT
HAPPENED," AND IT COULD BE A
BOMBSHELL.
>> Sean: TONIGHT, BY THE WAY,
WE JUST LEARNED THAT IN FACT WE
HAVE, OH, THAT TO GET THAT IN
FACT, OH, IT WAS CHUCKY SCHUMER
WHO WE LEARN CHUCK SCHUMER GIVE
A TICKET TO TOMORROW’S
IMPEACHMENT HEARING TO LEV
PARNAS, THE GUY INDICTED BY THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK.
I THINK THEY ARE SERIOUS PEOPLE,